The four-day week can benefit
workers, companies and society.
The research shows that
people are less stressed,
value their jobs more and have
better lives outside of work.
In most cases, they
are as productive
in four days as
they arein five.
The secret sauce is
work reorganization,
cutting out the least
productive activities.
Meetings are a
prime target.
Companies can also
see benefits
through lower turnover
and a higher-quality
applicant pool.
The four-day week is
a down payment
on a new way
to live and work.
And yes, we're going to
need government help
if we're going to move beyond
theinnovative companies
that already see its virtues.
But as the three-day weekend
spreads, we canrealize
everyone deserves a
right to free time.